cuz we're gonna be
it's about to be
Oh
[Music]
this was last Monday morning the wife I
[Applause]
[Music]
just want document like it's so obvious
to me what could happen daily bein
snapchat like our execution these next
four months it can be so [ __ ] crazy
what a lot of you'll understand is
execution and we put the piece of in
place a full execution I don't think
anything valuable comes back there's a
lot more of the Gary Vaynerchuk success
story than the overnights 24 months
everything happened for you success
story I wish everything I wish you got
to see lots of worth every minute every
day oh
Zorich sneakers in
you're not with them living alone
indie-rock yep so not letting us
upstairs because I don't have shoes for
them sneakers Jeremy get my teenager all
right they're letting them up okay how
do you have sex and a monkey the attacks
in the last year a piece of poop with I
just come in well yeah I think it's
gonna be because I do realize this when
we did it I guess this is going to help
put a cherry on top of the sundae of
like the work of the work there's no
talking about there's no going on the
askgaryvee show of popped indicating I'm
excited for you guys to continue on this
journey because get ready to be very
excited Tim Rickards Gary Vaynerchuk how
are you super well I have my calendar
that we're recording today I'm at the
door do you have setting [ __ ] man [ __ ]
people don't think of entrepreneurship
and a skill right they don't think they
can be LeBron or be you know Nine Inch
Nails or be severe ascent but everybody
looks at me and says I can do that if
you right now is your as you're running
through the airport or driving on the
highway or going to a job you my friend
are not an entrepreneur you may have
entrepreneurial tendencies being
entrepreneur a purebred entrepreneur the
way that I see is somebody who doesn't
even have the ability to have ever had a
job the reason I was an F student and
I'd like to think most of you realize at
this point I'm no dope I'm not a dummy
it was because I couldn't deploy going
from that machine which was built to go
get a job and I wasn't honing the skills
that I knew I had to have to be who I
was and I knew this at nine years old
amazing dog beautiful
put a dog I don't even like dogs I like
humans I don't give a [ __ ] about trees
[ __ ] nature animals all but the
people I know that bothers a lot of
people but it bothers me when so many
people don't like people like everybody
always get so mad at me when you're like
you only dogs you're bad guy you don't
care about Mother Nature you're bad guy
most of you won't like other people
you're bad guy tell you the number one
thing that scares the [ __ ] animation
nice watches and Ferraris here's what I
mean do not sell these people [ __ ]
very real it's got to be valuable
because you like money when your
grandkids ever think you're a dick right
understood it was an actual [ __ ]
business
you're not a [ __ ] self-help coach
that only sells info products it comes
down to very simple things which is do
not get caught up in taking a [ __ ]
pretty picture like on a vacation on
[ __ ] boat on Instagram and selling
these people [ __ ] everybody's doing
that everywhere you go you built a
business that's what you pound on and if
you happen to be motivating and
charismatic all about all the [ __ ]
manner
I think documenting your journey on
again medium your own personal blog
YouTube SoundCloud anchor you know on
and on and on snapchat on and on and on
of you going through this journey I mean
it would be really cool to have content
right now about when Vera Wang started
learning like literally learning how to
how to create a dress right what do you
think are the key ingredients to typical
story I think the best ingredient to a
good story is understanding what your
audience wants to hear okay and and and
so and so because I have so much
listening capability and so much empathy
I'm able to really understand what they
want to hear now what I think makes a
great storyteller
is not a good one is understanding what
your audience wants to hear and
understanding what you should tell them
predicated on that and allowing the
authentic most high-value information
get to them instead of pandering or
manipulating them the movie [ __ ]
Denver [ __ ] [ __ ] simple because
that's the current law why do I hate
Texas for my heart because I yeah I'll
tell you exactly right here faint I hate
Texas I listen I hate Houston more than
you [ __ ] hate the system right now
because I built a wine business where I
shipped wine and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
assets they two expects money the
politicians and blocks only one store
from shipping the Texas me because I was
at the top of the heap I was going
through a million in sales here saving
all Texas people money because I was
creating competition and the wholesalers
three of them paid more [ __ ] [ __ ]
asked Houston politicians to block me
from shipping here and one day I got a
letter and said you can't ship here
anymore so what am I supposed to do I
can open a store in [ __ ] Texas and
throw down or I can adjust that's what
you have to do nobody gives a [ __ ] about
your feelings bro who's an entrepreneur
in here raise your hand let me give you
one really really good piece of advice
the meanest is four billion times more
important than perfection the amount of
you that are crippled by getting [ __ ]
right
instead of getting [ __ ] done is insane
and it is an absolute variable to
success in an entrepreneur land where
you have to do something in those couple
years or you're [ __ ] dead go talk to
nine year olds they regret they talk
about regret I wish I did literally
inevitably I do this I wish is the
opening line hey man tell me about your
life like this is what I do
that's what I did in my 20s I spoke to a
lot of old people they'll end it and
that rule II literally one by one at
airport at Airport Park or Park Ave
enter event bar or bar
one of them every one of them all of
them started with I wish all of them oh
wow
pretty cool huh the office is so intense
look at this
Statue of Liberty alright my room is
legit guys I don't want to look at it
I'm so excited look if you want
something to happen you can't just
visualize it this isn't the secret [ __ ]
you need to actually have a plan on how
you're going to get there and more
importantly the bigger your ambition is
the more patience you have to deploy
against it the more working after put
against it it's just the way it is
obviously your talent is a variable
great you're gonna crush it making six
months do you that's fine just I always
see it and so the audacious wants and
needs of buying a alisha of a business
standpoint not a professional football
team even back then when it wouldn't
just worth a billion I knew this was
going to be five six seven billion
dollar execution so even though I did
great in the wine business even though
crushin had popped and I was building
the garyvee thing like and even though I
had invested a Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr at that point I still had the
self-awareness even though everything
was showing me with my investing that I
could make a lot of money that way I
still had the self-awareness that for me
what I thought was going to be my best
opportunity was to go and not start a
brand the idea of creating the next
Captain Crunch versus buying Captain
Crunch when the company that owned it
didn't manage it well and wanted to sell
it off there was just no no comparison
on stage and I I thought a really
interesting thing to talk about would be
self-awareness if I could spend two to
three minutes with all of you and make
you understand that self-awareness is
probably the single most important thing
that you can spend time on for your
outcome for your future life it would be
so exciting to me if hundreds or
thousands of people left here today and
started really realizing who they
actually were what are you actually good
at are you actually in a position to be
successful what do you like doing
because the opportunities are endless
the problem is we are scared
different things because the fundamental
core reality is we worry about what
other people say we worry about getting
judged
if we fail one thing that I've been very
blessed with because I've traveled the
world quite a bit for business and
speaking and one thing that a lot of
people may not understand is that
entrepreneurship does not work in a lot
of other countries because failure is a
scarlet letter here in the US we're so
lucky that entrepreneurship is met with
when you fail you pick yourself back up
and you go and to me that is
unbelievable and we are blessed to be in
that ecosystem and we need to take full
advantage of it